[Music]
now on to our first item what's the
state of play in america when joe biden
got back he found his party had lost the
big race in virginia a state which he
personally won by 10 percentage points
just a year ago
so freddie gray in his cover piece
portrays joe biden as a fallen superman
lying in the beach is that fair we
talked to jacob harbour who joins me now
from a vietnamese cafe in washington dc
and freddie joins me from well upstairs
in the office in london freddie are you
being a bit mean to um joe biden all
presidents will lose midterm election
how bad is this really
well i'm well aware that uh presidents
can turn things around
uh i suppose the point of my piece is
that the the outlook is very grim for
biden on all fronts
it wasn't just
uh virginia last night i mean he the
democratic party are failing all over
the country and more broadly his job
approval rating is collapsing
uh americans who think the country is on
the wrong track
uh are increasing it's about 71 percent
now uh there's a general sense that the
biden presidency is a disaster
and it's uh quite serious for biden
because for a long time he just surfed
off the fact that he wasn't donald trump
and that he wasn't causing the sort of
cultural aggravation that everybody
thought that trump caused
the trouble is now he seems to be
leading over a country doesn't know what
he's what it's doing
and that's a big problem for biden
jacob you supported joe biden as did
most spectator columnists who had a vote
in the election are you feeling a bit
disappointed now it seems as if you're
your man is beginning to lose the
electoral coalition after just a few
months
i think that uh unfortunately i can't
disagree with freddie as much as i
normally would with my usual
vigor
come on you could try you could try i
was expecting that freddy would be
gloating
this morning he's being fairly
restrained but there is much to gloat
over
and i think the principal difficulties
that biden is experiencing
are not are that he's not holy master of
his own fate
the
the russians in congress
between the democrats have turned into a
psycho drama over these infrastructure
and social spending bills so biden
really has very little
to show the electorate and that was that
certainly hamstrung terry mcauliffe in
the virginia elections this has been
compounded
by
the
almost parasitic infestation of woke
ideology
into american
schools and colleges which
the democrats kept announcing during the
virginia
election that there was no such thing as
critical race theory
that republicans were making this up and
that it isn't actually taught in the
schools
now this is i think somewhat
disingenuous while it's true that this
abstruse doctrine of critical race
theory
may not specifically be taught in the
schools it has become a code word
or a a broader term
for both woke
and cancel culture which have become
fairly pervasive in america
and in this regard
i think that biden may need to have a
sister soldier moment where he publicly
divorces and emancipates himself from
these ideologies
right but fairly this was supposed to be
the great advantage of joe biden wasn't
he basically he was too old to
understand what we were commenced
doesn't understand what navy's initials
meant but the strange thing is in
virginia and critical race theory was
not taught in any schools he absorbed a
lot of the political conversation
so at the summer expense do you think
the republicans are riding on a kind of
false narrative here they got away with
it this time talking about critical race
theories if it was a real thing in
virginia schools but it wasn't and maybe
verlock might not hold for that much
longer
i think there's an element to to into
which that glenn young in the successful
virginia uh
now governor of virginia uh exploited
the fact that he could disassociate
himself from trump or the red raw
elements of trumpism but he could still
appeal to the culture war fight over
critical race theory and he won on that
basis i think a lot of party republicans
are perhaps getting a little bit excited
over excited about this and they're
saying we have a we have a way out of
rep out of trumpism in which we can sort
of take the good bits the successful
bits of trumpism electorally and we can
get rid of the nasty stuff that puts off
most voters i think there's a little bit
of over-enthusiasm there this is just
one
one result but it definitely spells
trouble for the democrats because they
are lumbered with biden who personally
invested himself in this virginia race
and who ended up
losing and the fact that his
intervention didn't just not help it
seemed to actually make the situation
worse because his popularity is so bad
so going into the midterms next year
the democrats look to be in serious
serious trouble
and jacob when you look at who voted in
virginia there's a very interesting
passion a pattern that we hadn't really
seen since trump's first election in
2016. that is that the democrat vote
turned up as strongly as they thought
but there were the republican votes
turned up in even greater numbers and
it's where it turned up that matters
we're talking about the the places
outside the cities the far stronger
rural votes in other words it seems that
the people who turned up for trump in
2016 who didn't then show up in
subsequent midterms are for some reason
coming back so the trump coalition is
coming together at the same time that
the democratic coalition is falling
apart because we're hearing lots of of
civil war in democrats if you look at
buffalo and new york you've got there
and a competition between two democrats
one a self-styled um
socialist democrat the first socialist
and leader there for like 50 years who
was taking on a centrist democrat there
for one so we're seeing civil war in the
left but cohesion on the right is that a
fair analysis
i think actually it is uh
not only was younken able to mobilize
the
republican trump supporters but he was
also able to cut in deeply into the
independent voters by appealing on
issues of education
and taxes
so i put more credence into the younkin
victory than
freddie appears to i think youngkin does
offer the republican party a winning
formula for the midterm elections
and indeed
i suspect
that he will be a potent candidate for
the presidency in 2024.
junkin is not a professional politician
he is someone who is a highly successful
businessman at the carlisle group
and he
has toppled the last vestige of the
clinton empire i mean terry mcauliffe
was a constituent element
of bill clinton's runs for the
presidency he's a fantastic fundraiser
but he also has a reputation as a
sleazebag to put it bluntly
uh this is a tremendous
victory for the republicans today there
also
appeared to be on the verge of winning
the governorship in new jersey which no
one had even expected that to me is more
telling than the virginia election
the fact is
it's not the the democrats are whining
that the problem is messaging it's not
messaging it's the message that they're
delivering the message is not finding a
receptive audience right now
and freddie junkin's message certainly
did and i wonder what you think of
jacob's point that he could be a
presidential candidate because here's
somebody who's told his language was
quite restrained not at all nutty like
donald trump yet was still unafraid to
talk about critical race theory the
issues obviously matter quite a lot to
the people who voted for him so is he
proving that voters are being turned
away from the sort of more radical
aspects of democrats and are willing to
vote for a republican as long as he
doesn't sound like a nut
i think it's certainly true that if you
can be branded as an extremist by the
democrats when you're clearly not
you're going to win votes because what
young kim was doing was saying there's
this critical racist issue in critical
race theory issue in schools
and it's something that voters don't
like
and the democratic reaction to that was
you're a trumpist nazi effectively and
you're a racist and anyone who agrees
with you is a racist
and a lot of parents who are worried
about this said
no and these are not trumpist parents
they are sort of independent parents he
said no
we don't like critical race theory in
schools we're going to side with junkin
and that's what got him his swing
i i my point about whether young can can
work as a future republican candidate is
a it's way too early
but b
why why do we think that the republicans
have suddenly found a formula because of
one
race the point is they have fundamental
differences between the trump is base
that think the election was stolen and
it was interesting last night when the
results were coming in
a lot of the trump people online were
saying they're about to steal it they're
about to rig it it's all about to go
wrong because the democrats are in
charge
it that doesn't turn that doesn't turn
true so do we do we really invest faith
in this idea
that the republicans are going to find
some sort of happy middle ground between
culture wars fighting but not trumpism
so sort of amiable media-friendly
culture wars fighting i don't think
that's a recipe for long-term success
but
i'm very willing to accept i could be
wrong
freddie and jacob thanks very much
[Music]
you